yeah i was thinking of moving it to the
side yeah so maybe dash to the center
the reason i was thinking about maybe
moving forwards is to just support a
pawn push push harry the h41 square to
destabilize black's pawns david
we have an ex something called an
exchange sacrifice on the board and it's
a it's a meanie
look at dude's face as well he shook his
head and kind of raised his eyebrows in
appreciation
it's a great move yeah and okay we have
to show this but duda is down to 10
seconds so we have to keep an eye on him
as well because this move giving up his
rook on this square most humans would
never even dream of it bishop takes rook
it looks like you've just lost material
with white but after the pawn recaptures
look at these guys they're simply going
to march forward they're going to push
and become a new queen or at least force
black to give up one of his rooks or
knights to stop them looks good too to
me but
then white house gave themselves up
yeah
it's definitely drop this bishop back
precise till the end yeah and uh okay
young crystal he's frowning there but
he's got 15 seconds he needs a move
quickly
i just don't see a move for black the
white pawns are simply unstoppable
they're just gonna hold hands together
and march each other up the board
maybe you just have to make a move step
your rook okay
okay
now you can just walk your pawns through
to the destination and he's done it
okay rick is under attack needs to move
sideways
and as soon as that rook moves the other
pawn will step forward it's just game
over those pawns are too strong
and therefore duda just resigns about to
lose wow in the first game in the
quarterfinal win four magnus carlsen
with the white pieces logan christophe
he is not happy magnus not giving
anything away but this game david where
did magnus win it